[موسيقى]
اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من دير البلح وسط
قطاع غزه اهلا بكم اكثر من 7000 شهيد
بينهم 2900 طفل في القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل على قطاع غزه وعشرات الالاف بين
مصاب ومفقود وكتائب القسام تقصف غلاف غزه
وتل ابيب وضواحيها بينما تقول حكومه غزه
ان هناك مؤشرات عديده على استخدام اسرائيل
ذخائر محرمه
دوليا تشيع افراد من عائله الزميل وائل
الدحدوح من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلاح بينهم زوجته وابنه وابنته وحفيده
بعد استشهادهم في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف امس
منزلا نزحوا اليه وسط قطاع غزه وشبكه
الجزيره تحمل السلطات الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه
سلامه مراسليها وطواقمها في
غزه الامم المتحده تقول انه لم يعد هناك
مكان امن في غزه ووز وزاره الصحه في
القطاع تحذر من كارثه انسانيه بسبب تحول
المستشفيات الى مراكز ايواء والانروا تقول
انها ستضطر الى تقليص عملياتها الانسانيه
بشكل كبير ان لم يصل الوقود
فورا قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني يحذر من
ان استمرار المجازر سيغير المعادلات وان
النار ستحرق من اشعلها وعضو حكومه الطوارئ
الاسرائيليه بين جانس يقول ان الحرب ستكون
طويله ويتوقع تحديات صعبه في حين فشل مجلس
الامن الدولي في تبني مشروعي قرارين
امريكي وروسي بشان غزه الى
اللقاء